en 3h40 chez votre marchand de journaux
vous pouvez acheter de paris match dans
lequel on apprend dès la couverture que
cyril et le conseiller secret des
manuels matheron une révélation que baba
bien sûr direct pris au sérieux
je veux bien passer pour un con mais au
moins qu'on me prévienne avant quand on
feuillette le magazine on apprend
ensuite plein d'autres infos
croustillantes comme le fait que baba ne
comprends pas trop trop le principe du
téléphone il me dit on pourra s'appeler
je donne mon mail
et on découvre aussi que brûle de jeudi
qui porte une interview pendant presque
deux mètres une petite pression à cyril
vous même cyril vous vous définissez
comme un médiateur de la république vous
êtes sérieux vous êtes sérieux alors que
pour 40 centimes de plus vous pouvez
avoir télérama ou baba est carrément en
couverture avec un petit air inquiet et
aux pages 22 juste à côté d'une grappe
de raisin mal lavés page 23 on apprend
qu'il va faire le tour de france pour
encourager les jeunes à aller voter bref
on connaissait le film l'homme qui
murmurait à l'oreille des chevaux mais
sommes nous en train d'assister au
remake de baba l'homme qui murmurait à
l'oreille des manuels macron
alors c'est vrai que morse isabelle
d'être là et je voudrais qu on décrypte
un petit peu de ça parce que c'est vrai
que j'ai eu tout et n'importe quoi donc
isabelle va y répondre avec moi parce
que c'est vrai que ont même nous on est
parfois étonné des folies de ce qu'on
regarde et serré que vous pouvez nous
poser toutes vos questions bien entendu
vous aussi ici on va commencer avec
l'article de paris match qui est paru
aujourd'hui en une on peut dire si
l'ennemi n'a conseillé secret des
manuels mâcon sa première interview
politique alors c'est vrai que comme je
voulais d'hier je suis pas du tout le
conseiller des manuels macron voilà et
je les rencontrais deux fois comme je
voulais dit une fois lors d'une remise
de médailles une fois à l'antenne avec
vous et c'est vrai que voilà je parle
aussi bien emmanuel macron qui a peu de
la vie bertrand car jean luc mélenchon
voilà ou à d'autres voilà parce que
c'est vrai qu'au si on prépare les
émissions et que ont préparé une
émission politique donc on a envie
d'avoir tout le monde voilà ça mais ça
c'est sûr est ce que vous avez quelque
chose à rajouter
non c'était ça me paraît très haut pour
tout dire il si oui est-ce que vos
parents vous demandez à votre point de
vue sur un sujet scarpelli titre vous
zappez voilà il ya sur ce problème
qu'est ce que tu en penses donc j'ai pas
qu'est ce qu'il pense mais ça peut être
ça peut être à l'arrivée vous verrez
dans le livre c'est vrai que je parle de
tout ça et je dis voilà il m'arrive
d'échangés parfois avec le avec le
président ou avec d'autres hommes
politiques voilà qui me demande comment
tu sens les choses commencent à ce
moment ça se trouve c'est ça qu'est ce
qu'on a c'est ce qu'on appelait à une
époque les visites or du soir ce qui
faisait partie de la société civile et
qui vont à l'elysée parce que on a envie
pour moi j'ai jamais vu j'ai envie
d'aller vous maintenant moi je visais
personne en personne c'est par sms
séparés c'est pareil c'est ma souris
bien bien toi tu oui oui oui non moi
j'ai été très choqué par ce titre là
c'est le titre parce que là rien sur
bien fait tiquer correct c'est ça c'est
le ticket est accrocheur oui d'accord
c'est le but d'un journal d'accrochages
été pareil mais ça c'est dingue de dire
ça c'est énorme quand on sait que cyril
d'abord parle à tout le monde à tous les
partis on le sait ici dans cette
émission ce soit la france insoumise
dans luc mélenchon raquel garrido tous
les gens qui viennent les autres encore
hier le rn qui étaient là tout à l'heure
je regardais la télé ne sera pas bon ça
c'est la reine c'est ridicule de dire
qu'ils s'adressent ou qui les
conseillent de macro mais j'étais très
choquée par c'est vrai que ça c'est vrai
que le titre est un petit peu erronée
elle titrait putassier m'enfin c'est
le titre est effectivement tu es passé
en même temps vous leur avez mis un
petit taquet si je peux me permettre en
leur disant que vous ne vouliez pas être
en une fois deux fois dix fois dans le
théâtre peut-être voilà c'est ça dessine
un petit retour de bâton ce film
permettra donc je pense que c'est ça
mais je dois penser
et après c'est vrai que c'est moi je
trouve sa chique conseiller s'occuper de
moi j'aurais bien
conseillère sauvé face de maquereaux
neige comprends pas pourquoi on ne dit
pas parce que vous êtes déjà la
conseillère secrète de yanick jean
ce
qui se dit dans l'art tissé qui maniait
la sonde régulièrement sans trahir de
secret c'est sur quel type de sujet
c'est des sujets des taxes sur vos
tenues sur votre mac os nati par exemple
sur la campagne non non non non sur ils
s'intéressent beaucoup je vous dis à ce
que pensent les français à ce que
comment est la situation en france
comment on sent les choses sur le
plateau parce qu'on reçoit énormément de
jaune chanceux gens quand on a eu les
gilet jaune quand on a eu des gens voilà
quelqu'un en détresse et nous dit
comment tu les sens est-ce que le psy
qui vous regardent et nous regardent
voilà c'est surtout pour ça et c'est
comme voilà les autres aussi un gentil
mélenchon 6 voilà quand on l'a avec lui
voilà il sait qu'il va venir sur le
plateau on en change pour savoir qu'elle
est là le l'ambiance et que c'était un
oui mais ce que vous avez senti
justement parce qu'on ya un glissement
de l'émission de plus en plus on parle
de société on parle de politique et c
est ce que vous avez senti un glissement
de leur part a eu de tout l'appareil
politique qui depuis tous sollicités qui
viennent vous appelait alors
qu'auparavant ils vous appelez pas pas
autant que ça
puisque ça pas pas plus que ça vraiment
pas plus que ça c'est passé juste que je
suis plus en contact avec eux maintenant
puisque on prépare une émission
politique que l'émission reçoit souvent
des responsables politiques forcément je
le dis je suis plus en contact avec la
république en marche pourquoi parce que
ce sont eux qui sont au pouvoir et comme
j'essaie de mettre en contact des gens
qui veulent faire avancer les choses
avec les gens du pouvoir forcément je
m'adresse plus à la république en marche
voilà quand j'ai eu jean michel blanquer
air et quand j'ai fait un entretien que
jean michel blanquer c'est parce que on
m'avait arrive à les alerter sur plein
de choses sur les réseaux sociaux qui
avait plein de jeunes qui me disait il
faut que tu fasses quelque chose pour le
bac pour le bts et j'ai eu la chance
voilà pouvoir rencontrer jean-michel
bancaire et voilà d'essayer de d'essayer
de faire bouger les choses mais n'avait
pas besoin de moi mais c'est vrai voilà
c'est surtout sur des sujets mais
forcément comme se sauve comme c'est la
république en marche qui est au pouvoir
forcément on a plus de députés de
république en marche ici que pour
l'instant de la france insoumise voilà
on s'est peut-être que ça changera en
2022 voilà oui d'autres oui vous vous
dites comme dans le livre que l'ia
autant quasiment deux porte-paroles de
la république est en marche que de jours
dans l'année c'est quand même pas très
compliqué les avoir sur votre plateau
que ça se bouscule un peu ou pas
j'aimerais c'est vrai c'est vrai non
mais c'est vrai